hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're you gonna watch
from new rock stars one of the best
YouTube channel I've ever existed
avengers endgame Thanos battle new
Easter eggs revealed this came out like
a week ago and you just can't get enough
of endgame am i right huh am i right but
before we go into covering this video I
wanted to say another special thank you
to the folks over at perfect world
mobile for working with us this week
that's right guys after more than a
decade the classic MMO RPG is returning
and the best part is now you can play
from anywhere perfect world mobile
allows you to explore classic beautiful
3d environments create awesome custom
characters and engage in an array of
unique and exhilarating battles and
combat styles in short it's everything
you loved about perfect world revamped
to fit in the palm of your hand the game
hit nearly three million downloads in
its first 12 hours of release over in
China and the global English release is
on its way there's something for new
fans and old fans alike so be sure to
hit up our special pre-registration link
in the description box to sign up for
perfect world Mobile and join the fight
for the perfect world today people you
probably directed your rewatch attention
to that okay notice when the MCU trendy
make their initial approach to Thanos as
he waits for them in the rumble of
Avengers HQ their schools
a handful of debris from the rubble now
it's hard to get an accurate count on
these things the camera cuts
he's holding his hand was indeed about
this three on one point is how it
displays the relative strength between
the Avengers like with Anna's hits cap
cap goes lion-o with Anna says Thor a
god Thor takes a hit but mostly absorbs
it maybe it's over it's already occurred
right before the big cap wielding
million Bowman source women Stormbreaker
but then those intercepts it he swings
it upward and then pushes it closer
closer into Thor's chest
now this is a callback to Thor doing
this if Thanos an infinity war but also
it's someone suggests that Thanos might
be worthy of Stormbreaker
correctly the battle-axes kinetic energy
just a bit rather than like lifting it
also we should say that work so to speak
applied to the thinness of infinity war
the 2018 Thanos not this vanos who is
younger from 2014 and list of an
eco-terrorist seeking balance then a
straight-up genocidal fatal is seeking
to burn everything so even if there is a
version of Thanos who is worthy
was intended to establish him as always
worthy
[Music]
Thanos grabs capsule wrist not meal
nears handle or so perhaps this is
another clue not being worthy it's not
for the ground shoot lit half the
imagery of cap defeat it like this it
looks Tony's making their vision and age
of Ultron yeah this darkest moment shows
that think we're coming true
Natasha's death the return of leviathans
the directors are returning to that
imagery to make us feel complete despair
all is going on underground it's how we
need that already shows up wearing this
later the battle but here the
established how Scott was able to get
Rudy innocent warmer
yeah yeah that's cool that's really cool
[Music]
moves appear that initial collision
between lines cap under hand mill near
Nicole City in Thor lightning plows a
group Scott Lang punches just like old
sitting for behind and stabs the
shoulders with his daggers ensuing this
to freak or a sword trade sword burger
and you'll hear behind them Mantis
brings down a feast oh oh sorry Peter
Parker finally getting that hug that
Peter wanted and spread around
homecoming
starting tonight in same time reduce the
cap right no one looked at Scott gives
her a call back to that scene in and
what we call them captain for the
[Music]
[Music]
after this dream Denis's melee with
Captain Marvel Thanos Rissa Power Stone
out of the gauntlet punches are with it
the purple energy seems his hand and arm
with the stone and then the moment our
hearts stopped Thanos
nearly
that music thing there is actually the
same music that we heard all the way
back in the first Avengers the similarly
heart-stopping moment that Iron Man blew
the new crew the portal
that is so cool like vision is love
antique complet kids we're turning him
back to his empty gauntlet status front
post Quincy that started his whole stony
quest and his final breaths are shown in
the exact same camera movement now there
is one more possible easter egg that a
lot of people been talking about showing
up in peter burgers high schools and
closing montage there is a kernel which
sort one here and many are seen could be
doing now marble has not confirmed this
and they probably will never because
property oh wow that is yeah that's
pretty cool actually yes that's a cool
one to ponder comment with your favorite
new detail he's fighting from your
vendors in gay Paree watch that i know
you definitely did follow me on
instagram and twitter in Yvonne's and
subscribe give me rock stars a breakdown
thank you for joining me and now the
first two hours of this movie to rewatch
hey my friend
that's great guys make sure to subscribe
if you have a subscriber you rockstars
you got to do that
they are the new rock stars yeah I don't
know how big their team is dandy they
clearly they do their research had more
that Kobe she going frame by frame
through the whole film
I mean sometimes with these breakdown
videos and you know whenever we have
like a huge new trailer out lately we've
we've been doing like breakdowns for it
scouring those frames yeah you really
did go frame by frame trying to get
whatever you can from it trying to just
keep up with new rock stars apparently
or a Grace Randolph whichever one I
actually really like this trailer do you
end up like reaching really deep to try
to find something where you're like I'm
not sure if this is met and intentional
is this a tribute or is this an actual
thing pointed out anyway so you got like
these two here you got the six stones
that they're talking about the very
beginning but then you'll say I have the
potential Gwen Stacy not like the six
stones thing I think is a Reese it's a
bit of a region yes it could be though I
think the thing about making this kind
of video in general is you're gonna find
definite Easter eggs but since you're
looking so hard for them you're gonna
just make some yourself yeah yeah but
the gwen stacy what gwen stacy that
seems very possible the skirt especially
seems like that makes it intentional
that's way more believable to me then
when Kevin Feige was like yeah the
little boy from Iron Man 2 is spider-man
yeah that's neither tunity taken yeah
that one felt like yeah sure we could
say that it fits the chicks who's
timeline-wise yeah why not but the gwen
stacy one liked the design with the
backpack that blonde hair but then even
like the spiderweb type of skirt yeah if
they came out and said it there we go
yeah i totally believe it that was an
intentional thing on the production
design whether that means a
foreshadowing or just a nod or just yes
I'm they're cheeky I would totally buy
that so I think that's really cool my
biggest takeaway is the Thanos copter we
were robbed we were robbed we've been is
wrong there's gotta be something just a
little nugget of an Easter egg in a
future production design of a movie
where you see the Thanos come there's
there's a Marvel one take where after he
he says I'll do it myself and puts on
the gauntlet he gets in the copter and
the Corvus glaive is to assemble
they brought up an interesting point
that from the sound of it that other
people have already addressed that I
never thought about vanos does grab
Stormbreaker I know the rules of meal
nor were a lot more established just
since Thor one being worthy and it
seemed to have such a much longer
history and lineage Stormbreaker was
just created well five years five years
ago you know but in terms of its
existence it's not very long yeah and we
don't know the exact rules as compared
to me on there we just know that were
forged in a similar place right if
fortune that is similar the dwarves or
the dwarf the the dwarf would say yeah I
don't know of like how the milner rules
were was it like blessed by gods or
something like that to be worthy I'm
sure there's an answer to this so I
never read into it but that would be an
interesting theory because to me it just
did seem like a moment where you just
grabbed a weapon the thing he was
talking about Erica come here we're best
friends
oh yeah we text each other city chair
dick pics you know goes he's talking
about how he just wielded the kinetic
energy from like no I wouldn't even work
with Milner he's out there worthy or
Stormbreaker rules are not the same yeah
yeah or there's a plot hole in this yeah
all but all the crazy production design
details in there and then they didn't
they completely forgot about that
yeah they point out later on the he
grabs caps hand when Milner is in his
hand and they make a point out of that
suggests to me that maybe yeah just the
rules of Stormbreaker slightly different
I liked a lot of these nods like the
shockwave team-up move that there was
anon back to age of Ultron so faster
you're watching it honestly for
especially within game and not every
superhero movie gets to be in game
obviously but that's been my favorite
kind of Easter Egg for this is yeah like
the shockwave team-up little move they
do or even the music cue coming back at
the very end to mirror the first of
Ezzor
as a movie fan just like beyond comics
or whatever like those kind of nods
creating this to be the the bookend to
the infinity saga how fan owes his first
appearance in Tony Stark's departure
from the MCU having that musical nod
which I definitely did not pick up on
yeah
to me that's probably my favorite thing
out of this whole breakdown oh yeah I've
learned that that to me that's the
coolest thing they could have offered in
this video yeah it's like further
enhances that place in time
at all because then you think way back
and you go oh yeah that's right that
specific moment yeah yeah and I also
love to the way I mean there were some I
noticed in the film like the way that
the camera is the same motion around
Thanos that the Embassy's watching the
opposite version of his plan play up a
title so you know the stuff with his
cohorts coming up similar and dusting in
ways that the Avengers well yeah I mean
you got like the chorus clave way then
approximately no way in the back but it
seems like a cool not it seems like
pretty intentional what they were doing
there for that moment to mirror the wand
of vision moment they're talking about
the reunion stuff and I'm glad it wasn't
just a montage hey we should have had a
four-hour cut or there was just every
single idea they had Union a putter a
union I do kind of wish we it's cool to
slow it down and build hey there in the
background
Rocket Raccoon and and Groot it doesn't
look like a reunion moment to me though
the way they stated here sounds like
they were implying it was a reunion
moment but that it looks like they were
a rare moment in the battle it looked
like they already reunited they were
they were fighting yeah it looks like
Groot looked over I was like oh crap
it was with the amount of father-son
relationship that has been established
throughout guardians of the galaxy that
rocket isn't one of the main characters
and endgame that was such a
heartbreaking moment with group dying
and Infinity Ward and the Russo brothers
or the risk of brothers of the writers
Mars philia they said he was saying dad
in that moment which is really
heartbreaking I personally I would have
gone for an extra thirty Seconds to see
them reunion some way you know yeah for
sure yeah I was there some of them uh
they're one of the most beloved duo's
especially after the post first wave
Marvel characters you know and I'm so
happy they pointed out this moment with
mantis in the background because I've
heard so many jokes about what would
mantis even do in a fight well the
mantas do in battle well clearly they
thought of it and they put it in the
movie themselves I am super super glad
that's what it was captured here thank
you rock stars for doing that I do love
this ant-man continuity error I do love
a good continuity smooth over that's not
an easter egg but yeah like that's
definitely a thing that they they
probably were like we
just have to use the shot yeah most
people probably won't even notice
what are they notice though it's
possible that they might not have I mean
you know you're in Thrones people forgot
Starbucks cup and water bottles so I'm
sure it's easy in the midst of this
giant editing session that you're like
we probably should have CGI down a man
there yeah oh yeah one and I mean as
much as we all scour these frames you
know I'm sure these guys have seen them
so much that at a certain point you
might be looking at one thing and tweak
that one thing and completely missed
something across the frame that doesn't
make that much spider-man swinging on
nothing that's like a classic spider-man
to me whip to me I was like that could
either just be an error but it's such a
classic spider-man thing like what's he
swinging
yeah I remember watching this in the 90s
cartoon and that being like a little
trivia question they were playing
commercial ads yeah we just swing but in
New York he's clearly not like
connecting his webs to buildings cuz you
have to go like left to right not up to
me up no good could be an error or it
could be an intentional easter egg it's
so far away you know you could be one of
those kooky things that's like well this
is a super-wide anyway and plus it's
always been yeah get away with that well
this was great which one was your
favorite Easter a that you learn in this
video thank you new rock stars for
playing together this is so good
freaking he's my favorite movie of the
year guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
melih get notified whenever we have a
video up to check us on patreon we do
weekly Q&A z' TV show reactions several
of those shows have reaction highlights
included john does music video coverage
weekly now but let's see have a patron
today shot someone very special I don't
know this man's real name it's X
self-loathing X as pitched on patreon
for us we gave him a shout out on one of
our stranger things
reactions we were binge recording that
and I put out a post on patreon saying
alright people who are qualified for a
shout out reward to your comment if
you're watching stranger things and
we'll give you a shout out he commented
he was a brand new patron you know we
like to give these very personal life
shoutouts even though III had no idea
anything about him other than his name
would really know nothing about him I
don't even know if it's a him for sure
it could be a woman for all I know
anyone's capable of self-loathing right
we just gave a shout out based off of
you know his name and concept of
self-loathing
yeah there's a poking fun some I call
mean-spirited but you know we're speed
sarcastic we're just goofing around we
literally mean nothing personal because
we know jack about you but we saw that
you took offense to it
I apologize for offending you I'm only
apologizing as your patron if you're
just a subscriber double down double
down this would be a totally destroy the
insults yeah now that I have some
information about him I like to share it
here is from him my occupation is
loathing and what I've been up to lately
loathing is a lot of work so I've been
very busy with that there's an A in
loathing well we can't make fun of him
oh that's right this is it's a name
though so it's it's spelled names das
will get offended well you know I'm glad
that you're here and I hope that you're
not busy loathing 24 hours a day I hope
that you've got at least a couple hours
to yourself to appreciate just how
wonderful you are and how wonderful your
pledge makes us feel because despite
that first shout out clearly you care
enough to be here still for a second one
so maybe but maybe that's evidence of
the self-loathing because maybe the it's
reverse psychology maybe we should
double down because that'll make
self-loathing feel as yum what do you
want that's what I want to know what do
you want from us specifically
he got another youtuber to crossdress by
accident once but that's a whole other
story you can get me to crossdress on
purpose